hey this is will Antoni at e3 2017 Tony
you've played a game called dauntless I
have played a game called dauntless
you'd kill a bunch of big monsters with
a bunch of different weapons it's a lot
of fun cool okay so what kind of
monsters are you killing and what
weapons used to do that
well these masters are called behemoths
they haven't quite said of how many are
going to be in the final game but they
all come with various natural armors so
the first thing you want to do when you
tackle one of these pieces take a look
at okay this porcupine has a bunch of
quills I bet if I break those quills it
can't attack with them any more or
you'll get an enemy that has a big tail
you cut that tail off it can't attack
with the tail anymore so there's a lot
of tactics sort of when you look at the
biology of the behemoths that you're
fighting and you talk about it and I'm
reminded of Monster Hunter so what are
the similarities and differences I think
that's pretty fair the Monster Hunter
comparison so if you like monster hunter
it's probably a little bit up your alley
it is a free to play PC game so that's
probably the biggest distinguisher there
but similarity wise as we said variety
of behemoths and variety of weapons to
take them down so you can fight with
hammers which swing slower hit harder
swords which are kind of the happy
medium of damage in speed and the cool
thing about all your weapons is that
they all have special powers so for
example there's a sword that has sort of
an area of effect attack that you can
unleash that also buffs you for a little
while they've also added this new thing
called Lantern powers lantern powers are
basically like support abilities so for
example there's one that heals people in
your vicinity there's one that gives
over shields to people in your vicinity
so you can really sort of customize with
armor with weapons with powers and
really play the role that you want to
play during these hunts
so it's coming to PC free-to-play tell
me a bit about the social element of the
game
sure so what they've added now is
basically a central city and so you can
run around in there with your friends
that's kind of how you party up there
are merchants in there because you're
killing these behemoths and also finding
different flora and fauna out there
while you're fighting you can bring
those in to town and actually craft
stuff so that's how you can acquire your
new weapons your new armor their
multiple tiers of armor their multiple
tiers of all the weapons so there's lots
of stuff to find and craft and take back
out to kill more things to find more
things to craft again and so on and so
forth until you've killed to your
heart's content sounds awesome so to
learn more about dauntless check
gamespot.com
and we have an app now too so check
there for all the latest news
[Music]